hey everybody welcome back to another
episode of visual effects artist react
today we have Todd vasiri on the couch
this is a very historical moment for us
in the show because Todd is the first
active ilm member that we have had here
Todd has had a hand in some of the most
iconic shots in the past 20 years that
trailer shot that you remember from that
one movie yeah it was probably him this
is the first time we'll have ever seen
thai fighters in an atmosphere he's
going to break down some of these
moments from Star Trek one of the things
that was so great about this shot is
that it is extremely grounded Star Wars
real quick has anyone ever seen this
before no
this is exclusive
[Music]
possible to learn this power
not from a Jedi
oh we're kicking that right off with
episode three wow okay go to the most of
us as a percentage of how much work he
did on this movie was most of it in the
Mustafar system I think for me yes I was
mostly hanging out on mostafar with the
lava very hot very sweaty
lots of drama
so what you're seeing here in Mustafar
is a combination of basically every
technique that we would have available
to us yes the actors are against a blue
screen because there's no real set that
we could possibly build that would do
all this stuff but the lava the set it
is a combination of computer Graphics it
is a a bunch of Miniatures the lava down
there is a combination of computer
graphics and miniature lava what was the
lava surely it wasn't actually lava
the lava in certain shots was this
methicil concoction that they came up
with like basically the stuff that's
used as filler for shakes oh oh okay
they had to do so many tests for motion
for movement how thick how viscous it
should be It's all under lit from the
bottom because it's semi-translucent and
they realize this is the best way to
control how bright the lava is how fast
the lava is we have to shoot at
different frame rates we have to shoot
at different scales to get all this
stuff to work right I mean it was it was
a remarkable achievement
then we get into the computer Graphics
which are water simulations and stuff
that was headed up by like Willie Geiger
and stuff like that so like those big
splashes and eruptions of lava flying up
those are the simulations those are not
the simulations well okay that's the
third way we did some of the lava which
is monetna just happened to have been a
Lucas said hey let's send a camera crew
over to Sicily and film some stuff and
not just any camera crew Ron Fricke one
of the most amazing Motion Picture
photographers if you've ever seen Baraka
everybody should go see Barabbas Baraka
it is absolutely stunning and beautiful
Ron Ricky and his team shot lava blast
that's real lava right there that that
blast on the right uh is real the
silhouette shot that comes up later when
their lightsabers Clash
those are all real lava blasts in Sicily
that silhouette shot is an iconic shot
it's like the shot I remember from this
entire movie so far sequence that's
really great uh thank you for saying so
we have computer Graphics installation
back there I believe Brett Northcutt
painted that Sky back there we have some
computer graphic smoke and real smoke I
added tons of real smoke in this shot
but I'll tell you one of the hardest
things about this shot technically
was how to get those lightsabers to read
against the law oh my God you're right
right I have struggled with that myself
so many times like here's a bright thing
in front of a bright thing yeah it's all
just gone yeah lightsabers and in this
era they are additive they they are
sources of light how do you give the
feeling of a blue two blue lightsabers
against a super hot you know almost as
bright as the sun light stars back there
I'm gonna take a guess because it seems
the only thing that is actually white is
the lightsaber all of the lava is nicely
exposed again this is pure speculation
but then also just kind of dialing up
the blue uh glow on the lightsabers it
is a little bit of dialing up the blue
but the blue combined with the red comes
up with some very unpleasant colors that
are very non-star Wars like and it's
basically like creating all these mats
around the lava to cheat the saturation
of the lava behind it so that the blue
becomes prominent and I'm also being as
careful as I can to make sure at the
beginning of the shot that you still see
some beautiful clear blue lightsaber and
eventually it gets wiped away with maybe
a more amorphous lightsaber but the
Persistence of vision I'm hoping that at
the beginning of the shot you're just oh
yeah of course they're blue lightsabers
so are you actually taking the glow from
the lightsaber and basically using that
as a mask to change the color of the
lava right beneath the glow of the
lightsaber yep wow yeah so if you were
to turn off the lightsabers and uh see a
little bit more of like the raw original
plate you would actually see these gray
swishes going through the lava where the
lightsabers will be that is I like that
wow I had no idea that they were going
to use the shot in like the marketing
and stuff oh really it's like you know
they it was like one of the big trailer
shots I I'm glad they didn't tell me
Doom not tell me when something's going
to be used so heavily in the marketing
because I do not need that pressure I'm
having I'm having a hard enough time
just struggling through the shot and
making your photo real
it is so hot to be that close to Lava
they're Force pushing the heat away yeah
exactly it's great how they can
multitask that's some good head Cannon
right there I love it
oh wait you did Anakin on fire
I burned that kid up
fortunately third degree burns don't
hurt
so the lava we're seeing underneath
Anakin there is that more of the
methosome yeah that's stuff that was
shot on stage here's some of the
elements that were shot on stage real
quick has anyone ever seen this before
no
explicit
to bring you something special oh them
this is
yeah you so you're seeing like this
particular past is solely for the
interactive light the glow okay the lava
on to the Berm so I wouldn't even use
this berm I would just use the luminance
of that berm it's like a screen or add
mode onto like the other Berman yeah
very cool okay yeah you can totally see
the scale of the miniature here like the
entire Hill that they're on is about the
size of a dude every single one of these
Mustafar shots has a suite of passes
like this that the compositors had to
deal with we had a really great team Pat
tubach Mike Conte amazing leads amazing
artists and and hopefully nobody's even
thinking about that stuff they're just
thinking about Anakin and Obi-Wan
absolutely
that when when the fire first ignites it
was like kind of satisfying actually I
was like yeah all the fire you're seeing
is practical fire that was shot on stage
do I see a bone there uh there's a tiny
little bone there I mean I think when we
got to the point where somebody said
that looks like at the end of a stogie
like a cigar I was like okay I think
we're there
cannot go any further so we went through
a lot of iterations on that so our stage
crew filmed various pieces of wood and a
sphere almost like a basketball almost
puppeteering the gross movements the
biggest movement of his arm right the
biggest movement of his head and we just
let the cameras roll and we tried to
record as much as we could we knew we
were going to be getting thousands and
thousands of frames of this and I was
going to look through all that footage
for the best pieces of footage finding
the best little bits like when his hand
is up and and then his hand slams back
down I had to make sure that I picked a
piece of this footage that would work
I imagine he goes through costume
changes over the course of the sequence
like he starts out he's got all his hair
but by the end of the sequence he's got
like no hair basically there's Hayden in
the costume and then there's Hayden in
the makeup and there's nothing in
between oh wow okay yeah so we had to
figure out a way to disguise that in the
sequence how to make that work I really
wanted to show off the detail in his
shoulder that the makeup people did yeah
which is static there's no interactive
light on it at all there's no real fire
so getting a good track of that stuff
and putting in uh burning steel wool
elements and using the contouring of the
makeup to try to set it back like in so
it almost feels like he's internally
burning at that point I was like okay
I'm gonna try this I don't know if this
is going to work at all it might look
absolutely terrible and like that first
or second take looks so great I was like
oh God I hope they like this
I'm seeing so many different smoke
elements how many smoke elements are
there because I'm seeing like little
wisps here little is there I use a bunch
of different elements from you know
action the effects and whatnot and they
have like a little wisp but then if you
want to fill out a whole shot you have
to use like dozens of them is that what
you're doing here that's a lot a lot wow
wow
yeah you can see all the different smoke
elements
oh that's a lot but you know what's
really cool about this at the same time
like it's a lot of work but there's
nothing going on here that you just you
can't just do on your computer with
After Effects right now nope but kids
out there don't don't play with fire
please just be careful just do it in CGI
how do you feel about Star Wars prequel
memes I've seen so many memes of people
roasting marshmallows on their Grill and
you know with the audio of that scene
balance to the force
please continue to send it to me I think
it's wonderful and hilarious that people
are still thinking about this movie all
these years later that sequence did have
an effect on people and it's something
I'm really proud of
the soul is completely gone
May rock paper scissors too just dropped
on the corridor YouTube channel after
you finished watching this episode maybe
consider go checking it out
[Music]
so you worked on 2009 Star Trek yes the
Kelvin type line
really fun because I hadn't actually
ever been into Star Trek growing up and
so this was kind of like one of my first
big introductions to it and I loved it
it's kind of a big shot yeah another
iconic trailer shot just you know we
need to hear iconic trailer shots I
guess everyone just calls up Todd
one of the things that was so great
about this shot is that it is extremely
grounded we all know what construction
sites look like I love construction
it's rooted in reality this is a plate
of Chris Pine on a motorcycle in a field
and a lot of those tanks in the mid
ground are actually there in the
photography okay I wondered yeah a real
Dolly you know real camera move this is
a render of our Enterprise that Tom
fijis did that then our environment
supervisor christoski would then paint
over and okay hold up sorry to interrupt
sure sure that's a full finished fully
formed ship that we're seeing here but
all of the the construction details the
inside of the ship was painted onto that
yeah right we we spent all the effort
making a finished complete beautiful
full Enterprise and we decided that
running a render of the Enterprise and
then having it be an elaborate animated
matte painting after the fact was the
smartest way to do it it's really cool
and that that was the basis of the whole
thing so you have these really tall
construction lights on the right side of
the frame and anybody that's shined a
camera with a lens on it at a light
tends to notice that you've the lights
get flipped and they appear in reverse
on the opposite side of the frame but
very dim so you have a big tall stack of
vertical lights on the right then you
have the flipped lens flare version of
the stacks on the left that had the
inverse motion jiggle and bounce
is that an effect or was there actually
tall lights on the set there are no
lights on the set
that is something I put in and I fought
so hard to keep in iPods now very much
so yes
but it's one of those things that
led to the the authenticity of it and
it's it's hopefully not showy but that
is exactly what it is and it is a lens
flare it's the inversion uh flipped and
flopped of those lights which are
ostensibly aimed right at camera and you
would actually get that stuff I only
have a mountain of photographic evidence
to show that this happens and uh so uh
Roger and Russell Earl thank you for
letting me keep that in we got in front
of JJ and he liked it so the whole
shot's lovely it's a cool shot uh Chris
did an amazing job in the painting Tom
features was Mr the manager to the
Enterprise uh and and we get to show it
off on the last shot of the movie in all
of its Glory
four
I think the same director for both Star
Trek and Star Wars does feel
sacrilegious it's also great in dailies
when somebody accidentally says the
Enterprise or the falcon or vice versa
[Music]
there we go
how much of this shot is real is that
like an actual real shot of the sun
overlooking like clouds and mountains or
is it all CG or the mountains are based
on some photography the clouds are based
on some photography it's essentially a
synthetic shot we altered it enough so
that it's yeah can you elaborate on what
you mean by synthetic synthetic in that
it's made from nothing it's made from
and that can be computer Graphics it can
be a model or whatever but I'm just
saying something that is not one for one
live action filmed in front of a camera
not gonna I hadn't really heard that
term in this context before but I really
dig it I think I'm gonna have to use
that myself because it is uh if you if
you want to be precise and you're using
the term computer Graphics or whatever
that's great go ahead and do that but to
me synthetic is a catch-all to say this
was constructed this was created I love
it yeah not off the shelf what inspires
this shot one of the things that JJ
wanted to do with the force awakens is
to rely on the iconography of Star Wars
as we know it but in different uh
contexts this is the first time we'll
have ever seen thai fighters in an
atmosphere what does that look like what
does that feel like where's the where's
the heat ripples where's the everything
about it how do they fly so that's
something Paul Kavanaugh the animation
director had to deal with and then I had
this idea of like okay these Tie
fighters it's like well what's keeping
them up and I was like wait a second
they there's a power source there must
be some exhaust or something could they
be doing some exhaust like out the
bottom of the bulb and I asked around as
Pablo Hidalgo the the bigwigs that uh
lucasfilmed can I do this and they're
like yeah do it man that dictate the
Canon of how Tie fighters work go for it
yeah I thought TIE fighter stood for
twin ions yeah Fighters
as well so
um in this particular version you could
see it most on the on the ones on screen
right and it comes up in dailies
everybody's really happy and like oh oh
it's going to be in that first trailer
oh that's great oh that's all awesome
I'm like I'm so proud a couple days
later
hey Todd it's not in the trailer anymore
we're in a slightly different direction
for the trailer it's like oh that's a
real bummer oh yeah uh they're they're
playing with the edit and it's also not
in the movie anymore
all and I was devastated I'm like I put
so much into it and it's not in the
movie many months later
somebody comes up to me and Whispers hey
I think they're using it in the
international trailer or something uh
yeah don't don't get my hopes up don't
get my hopes up sure enough it was in
the international trailer and people
really liked it and it was the Masthead
of the banner of all these articles and
stuff and then we got the call you know
oh they're moving some stuff around it's
back in the movie
I cannot take this this is too much my
heart cannot take this
take this being that has ever had an
omen to have it come back and it
happened to this wonderful shot and it
also gave me a chance to go back in and
maybe do some things because I had to
change it for continuity reasons so if
you go back and look at the trailer
version and you look at this version
they're slightly different but
here's a lesson kids maybe you shouldn't
go back and adjust stuff because I feel
like the trailer version of the screen
left TIE fighter you could really
prominently see its heat Ripple in the
trailer version and here I blew out the
Sun a little bit too much maybe it's
more natural or whatever but kind of
miss seeing it on that typewriter and I
don't know I'm a little regretful so it
was a roller coaster for that shot and
I'm so thrilled that people like it I'm
really proud of it but boy behind the
scenes I was like
I'm stomach going up and down that's a
great story the culture at ilm is their
ideas can come from anywhere and anybody
can can speak up and and say their piece
and have an idea for a shot or a
technique frequently that's what you see
on the screen it's something I'm very
proud of of the culture at ilm and
that's what makes it never ever boring
Todd thank you so much for sharing all
of your wisdom and knowledge and
experience with us here today and with
all of our audience I didn't realize how
much of a trailer guy you are you are
literally the trailer guy
I love trailers it's like I can just see
them behind the scenes being like yeah
we need a shot who's gonna take care of
it it's like you already know who's
going to take care of it it's going to
be Todd the series he's gonna take care
of that trailer shot but don't tell him
yet don't tell me don't tell me I don't
want to know you're very well spoken
about visual effects um if people wanted
to hear more from you see what you've
been saying like stuff you've posted
where should they follow you uh well uh
check out TV series.com or just go to
the movies you know completely see
movies go to the big screen guys don't
forget we have a whole nother YouTube
channel called Corridor and we just
dropped our most ambitious project of
the Year anime rock paper scissors 2 is
out now you can click on the link on the
screen or in the description go check it
out thank you so much and to all of you
thank you so much for watching can't
wait to see you guys the next one